Từ tướng nhân hoàn tất cả đình bị chức năng phải từ giỏi sách sĩnh biến cục cầu,
nhất là các mặt hàng thiết yêu nơi lưng thực thực phẩm, sang râu và sĩ khu vật tài để kì thời có phương ăn nếu tiết,
càng thiệt hiệu qua.
Bình thành việc đàn bảo hồi công, tụ tử cục yêu cầu xích xặt công tắc thình chà,
kìm chà việc chất hàng quy định về địa ít giá và bán lúng về địa điểm đi quyết.
Toc hình vì găm hàng đô cơ chực lời hoặc lợi dụng như cầu một sám quyết năm để đu rá cầu bất thường,
phải được sử li như mình theo quy định của pháp lật.
Đông thời lực lượng khoảng li thì chiều của hộp với bán chỉ đạo ma tăng chính,
các cấp cân tăng cường đấu tranh chống của lâu, sang lận thương mại và hàng già.
Không để hàng kèm chất lượng xâm nhập thị trường,
làm mạnh hưởng đến xức khải vào quy địa lợi của người tư dông.
Sẵn sông sông với các biển pháp khoảng li, chính vụ quyết thích các địa phương đệ mạnh chính trình bình ổn thị trường.
Tổ chất các liển bán hàng lưu đồng về nông thôn khu công nghiệp, nhằm phục khủ công nhân và người lâu đâu.